you love obviously you're just a
naturally gifted comedian you've come up
with oh yeah yes you are you but you're
so funny but you've come up with this
idea that there are certain words you
like to say right there's certain words
that give you pleasure you think of I
like to say the word bulb is bow this
I'd love to say buh-booge buh-booge
anorexia stuff like that yeah
uncomplicated big word yeah but what I'd
love to do on stage I'd like to do my
impression of what's-his-name Nixon I so
the suits the worst Nixon impression
I've ever seen
[Applause]
oh good I gotta go home a John with who
can't phone that stuff in when you're
doing this down well I will channel
you'll channel Nixon and become good at
gentlemen first watch it was all dr.
Zaius remember I told you doctor glad
back said I'll children Channel dr.
Zaius from plan of the age huh when he
was on the beach remember when they had
him tied up yeah he's a zero Cornelius
and I mean zero Cornelius and timing so
that's where you went right now he was
that you're like that shirt what you got
a you got a nice big bird on the right
ear you got a pink shirt on a guy and he
loves me here on there's a guy in the
audience he's got a burn on his hand to
his old black woman remedy put some
butter on it my grandma my grandma burn
when I was a kid she said put butter on
that
do you know what they talk about she
wasn't black
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you